[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport c'est parti à pour le sommaire
de cette émission
foot us en deuxième division les
templiers d'elancourt se sont imposés 51
0 contre les joggers de nantes victoire
qui permet aux élans courtois d'espérer
une qualification en playoffs le résumé
de la rencontre dans ce magazine
football ont joué les quarts de finale
de la coupe des yvelines mort passé
brillamment imposé contre montigny le
bretonneux le score 4 à 0 au tour sur la
rampe en dans ce set 8 sport automobile
2 heavy noise vont participer au rallye
des gazelles la course d'orientation est
programmée du 13 au 28 mars dans le
désert marocain
nous les recevrons sur ceux à plateaux
actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tb 68
on commence donc par du football
américain dans le championnat de
deuxième division les templiers à
d'elancourt recevait les dockers de
nantes ce week end les élans courtois
qui veulent remonter en d1 à cette année
n'ont pas eu de soucis à se défaire du
piège nantais des images de mathilde et
demi les templiers d'elancourt en mode
rouleau compresseur les élans courtois
n'ont pas fait de détail ce samedi 22
février à domicile contre les dockers de
nantes
les élans courtois l'emportent sur le
score de 51 0 après avoir dominé
l'ensemble de la partie c'est une belle
victoire
on a on a été plein partout autant en
défense qu'en attaque
franchement ça fait ça fait vraiment
plaisir de voir que mes coéquipiers
prennent du plaisir et du coup voilà on
a on a montré ce qu'on avait à montrer
maintenant certes on a fait beaucoup de
fautes et qu'on va apprendre de nos
erreurs et référent essayer de faire
nous au classement les templiers
d'elancourt se replace cette troisième
victoire en quatre matches leur permet
d'occuper la deuxième place de leur
poule derrière les léopards de rouen les
playoffs de fin de saison sont donc
accessibles ainsi qu'une montée en
première division c'est un objectif
maintenant on en est encore loin
là c'est plutôt en phase de playoffs on
pourra avoir une vraie indication sur
sûr sur cette question mais ça reste un
de nos objectifs
maintenant c'est une marche qui est très
très hot on a encore beaucoup de
beaucoup de travail et pas mal de
matches mais on va on va pousser en fait
au plus loin pour atteindre cet objectif
prochain match pour les templiers
d'elancourt le 1er mars sur le terrain
des diables rouges de villepinte
en attendant les élans courtois peuvent
savourer
il y avait également du soccer du
football ce week-end en régionale 2
trappe se met en difficulté les hommes
dit cham zerg qui se sont inclinés 2-1
en match en retard contre eux ou ce
dimanche au classement trapé toujours
avant-derniers de r2 et devra se
ressaisir dimanche prochain contre
champigny à l'extérieur on jouait
également des matches en retard de
première division de district carrière
grésillons s'est imposée 5 à 0 face au
pecq une équipe forfait général pour la
saison dans ce côté bailly noisy
s'impose 3 1 contre hardricourt au
classement carrière grésillons est 10e
et bailly noisy à 6e une partie à des
quarts de finale de coupe des yvelines
était programmée à ce week-end montigny
le bretonneux recevait homme mord pas un
match où il n'y a finalement pas eu
match les morlaisiens se sont facilement
imposés à 4 à 0 en contrôlant le match
le résumé la rencontre
un montage de xana montigny le
bretonneux mort pas c'était l'une des
affiches de ces quarts de finale de
coupe des yvelines dès l'entamé du match
maurepas qui évolue en d1 de district
assume son statut de favori sa division
d'écart leur patient se procurent les
meilleures occasions et arrive à marquer
deux fois 2 à 0 ce sera le score à la
pause ça se passe pas très bien on a
respecté les consignes du coach
après ils ont marqué sur une attaque
rapide et
on se fait contrer ils ont une deuxième
au casque qui met au fond voilà pour moi
c'est de faire le nécessaire pour
revenir au déjà 2 1 après poussé pour
ces d'égaliser sur un peu juste garder
la possession c'est de faire ce qu'on a
fait en première mi temps gardé le même
système tranquillement le troisième va
venir sûrement tout seul ça va s'ouvrir
un peu plus d'espacé se livrer pour
sortir pour me remettre le premier pour
nous titille un peu mais sans le savoir
le défenseur tristan feely a vu juste
quelques minutes après la reprise ils
coupent belfodil réalise un petit numéro
dans la surface avant de marquer à 3 0
savage arriva j'arrive à bien effacer
finale avec un petit piqué franchement
c'est j'ai bien aimé cela mais après je
garde tous et des buts
baup à bout un but un but pas encore
rassasié yacoub belfodil s'offre même un
triplé en fin de match meurent pas
l'emportent 4 à 0
c'est frustrant on se fait éliminer
salma et non bref pas grand chose à dire
nous à part que match de coupe on aurait
dit elle était un peu plus de leurs
armes étant rentrés dans à l'envié on a
maîtrisé on savait que on savait qu'on
avait les qualités des vhu défense est
fait aux français pour pouvoir faire la
différence sur une division en dessous
ont conservé et qu'on partait avec un
petit avantage
après voilà maintenant on a su on a su
montrer les cartes cave entre nous le
prochain tour de la coupe des yvelines
est programmée le dimanche 5 avril
on continue à parler de ce match vous
l'avez peut-être vu sur ces images la
rencontre entre maurepas et montigny le
bretonneux a été arbitrée par une femme
cécile à bessières est une habituée des
matchs de district elle fait partie des
quatre arbitres féminines dans le
département un chiffre qui devrait
augmenter dans les prochains mois deux
arbitres sont actuellement en cours de
formation
peut-être pour être tout à fait complet
sur cette coupe des yvelines nous allons
voir tous les résultats de ces quarts de
finale maurepas s'impose donc 4 à 0
contre montigny le bretonneux coignard a
réussi l'exploit en éliminant le tenant
du titre 2-1 le 9 février dernier bailly
noisy s'est imposé 7 à 0 contre maisons
laffitte et hardricourt s'est qualifié
en battant aux tirs au but et l'encours
anjou est également sur les terrains de
rugby dans le championnat de fédérale 2
plaisir s'est incliné 38 à 13 sur le
terrain de beauvais ce week-end une des
meilleures équipes de la poule au
classement les plaisirs oies sont
toujours à la limite de la zone de
relégation avec un point d'avancé
sur orléans si tout ne va pas bien pour
plaisir le ciel est dégagé pour
versailles promu cette saison en
fédérale 3 les versets ayant engrangé
une nouvelle victoire en s'imposant 25 à
7 face à rueil cette dixième victoire en
16 matches permet aux joueurs de la cité
royale de conserver leur troisième place
au classement
un dernier mot de rugby faille invite à
fêter sa première titularisation
contrôlé avec les moins de 20 ans contre
le pays de galles ce week end sportif à
mort passe dix ans mensurations
impressionnantes de mai 0,3 et 110 kg a
joué lors de la défaite 14 à hong kong
14 à 11 contre les gallois
le deuxième ligne a joué la première
période prochain match contre l'ecosse
le 6 mars prochain
on va maintenant ouvrir une page sport
automobile le départ du rallye des
gazelles approche la course
d'orientation exclusivement réservée aux
femmes sera programmée du 13 au 28 mars
dans le désert marocain nous recevons
sur ce plateau de asie blinoise qui vont
participer à cette aventure melaine
ventes de la belle et cécile avis qui
travaillent à fontenay-le-fleury bonsoir
ça alors est-ce que tout est prêt avant
le grand départ à tous préparent on
finalise les derniers petits détails
mais ça ça arrive vite
ça va vite ça m'a dit vit aujourd'hui
départ donc oui la très prochainement
tout commence à se bousculer un petit
peu aussi bien dans nos têtes que pour
la voiture
est ce que la pression monte un petit
peu un petit peu quand les gens nous en
parlent en tout cas je pense que toutes
les deux ça va mais quand les gens nous
en parlent effectivement la pression non
parfois
alors pourquoi avez vous décidé de
partir ensemble alors l'idée principale
vient de ma tête
le rallye des gazelles ça fait des
années que je le suis et tout vient de
ma tête mais voilà rendent folle je suis
une fan de par le rallye parce espié ses
valeurs ce qui peut refléter mais je me
devais partir pour moi même y avait pas
trop d'intérêts en tout cas et je
voulais partir pour défendre une cause
donc on travaille actuellement dans un
esat on accompagne des personnes en
situation de handicap psychique et de ce
fait je pensais que cette cause voilà
pour moi il était c'était une belle
cause à défendre aujourd'hui y goûterez
affrontent les plus rien je peux
rappelle alors comment vous allez vous
partager les rôles dans la voiture ça se
passe et comment on va voir un pilote
qui est copilote
on a pas il n'y a pas de rôle
définis au préalable on peut être l'une
comme l'autre pilote copilote je pense
qu'on va faire en fonction de nos deux
noms du moment
en fait si on sent mieux dans une partie
ou dans l'autre on va faire un stage là
à la fin de ce week-end où on va
justement apprendre le pilotage vraiment
sur sable et donc du coup on verra
si on se sent mieux dans un domaine ou
dans un autre et puis frau feeling parce
que c'est un avantage justement de ne
pas avoir de pilote le copilote attitré
peut-être je pense que si on a une des
deux camps car peu plus fatigué d'un
poste ou de l'autre elle peut le dire à
l'autre et dures en échange
alors comment vous préparer pour ce
rendez vous alors on a un coach sportif
qui nous suit depuis quelques mois ou
qui nous entraîne à tout ce qui est
physique parce qu'on était c'est un
domaine qu'on connaît pas du tout et
donc ça fait
trois quatre mois qu'ils nous préparent
physiquement aux charges lourdes à la
conduite avec un peu sportive après on
se prépare aussi mentalement parce que
c'est des conditions qu'on ne connaît
pas si du bivouac
on est dans des tentes
voilà on n'est pas dans des hôtels 4
étoiles mais mentalement sous va bien en
tout cas ça va sur vous supporter les
charges de travail
oui oui bien sûr on supporte des charges
de travail notre directeur faire en
sorte aussi qu'effectivement on soit
plus ou moins des charges et en fonction
des rendez vous on peut avoir
donc oui il n'y a pas de souci on est
bien entouré en tout cas aussi au niveau
de notre établissement
quels sont vos objectifs sur ce rendez
vous c'est un objectif sportif avant
tout avant tout ce serait plutôt de la
communication sur le handicap psychique
faire parler du handicap psychique
briser les tabous sur ce handicap qui
peut faire parfois peur effectivement et
là faut qu'on brise tout c'est toutes
ces barrières en tout cas nous on les
réinsère professionnellement et on
voudrait aller voilà ou de la faire
comprendre aux entreprises fait un pas
en avant
essayez de les intégrer avec vous et
vous verrez ça se passe bien non les
accompagne aussi ils sont pas laissés à
l'abandon dans les entreprises est de
cette façon là effectivement on arrive à
me faire beaucoup de choses avec eux si
je comprends bien vous voulez finir la
course avant tout également oui oui
c'est le but c'est d'arriver
c'est d'arriver à la fin on n'a pas
l'objectif d'arriver les premières c'est
pas français pas forcément l'objectif
premier mais c'est dessus de la finir et
surtout de la finir pour que ce soit les
travailleurs que nous accompagnons soit
fier de ce qu'on parle du parcours qu'on
peut faire puisque si nous on est
capable de faire ça eux aussi sont
capables de faire plein de choses
alors c'est une première expérience pour
vous est-ce qu'on n'avait pas un petit
peu peur de vous retrouver dans ce
désert marocain
ça va pour le moment état de fait
pression pour leurs trousses derouet
après il ya toujours on va toujours
avoir des appréhensions je pense qu'on
va passer par des hauts et par débat par
des rires par des larmes mais on sait on
s'y attend et donc je pense que on est
consciente de ça et je pense que tout va
bien se passer
justement comment a réagi votre
entourage bah moi ils sont treize ans
trouveront conjoint qui et pédicures
podologues il en parle à tous ces
patients monfils en parle à l'école en
permanence encore aujourd'hui parler à
l'école qu'on passait aujourd'hui à la
télé donc je suis très très bien vendre
quelque chose d'assez fier alors vous
voulez aider également 60 personnes à
venir au maroc ainsi si j'ai bien
compris tout à fait en fait on
on cherche toujours des dons donc pour
financer le voyage parce que nous c'est
un coup pour pour partir effectivement
entre les voitures
le pour partir pour nous il faut compter
une quarante 40 mille euros à peu près
juste pour partir à deux
mais partir pour parler du handicap sans
emmener les personnes qu avec qui on
travaille ça n'avait pas de sens pour
nous donc on voulait qu'ils participent
à ce rallye les faire participer
proprement dit aura lire lui-même c'est
un peu trop compliqué pour eux donc ils
nous viennent nous retrouver à la halle
arrive à essaouira donc le 28 et le
c'est aussi un coût donc on cherche des
dons pour pouvoir financer ce voyage ils
seraient une soixantaine à nous
rejoindre sont là justement pour vous
aider alors on a une cagnotte sur et
l'oiseau les côtes razel vous pouvez
faire un don c'est déductible des impôts
aussi bien pour les particuliers que
pour les entreprises dernier dernière
chose avant le départ qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter
elle va le meilleur qu'on arrive au bout
voilà tout simplement que ce soit une
belle aventure et que
et que ça fasse bouger surtout ce regard
sur le handicap psychique
merci à tous de passer sur ce plateau
vous souhaite beaucoup de réussite pour
ce rallye à dégazer n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer une carte postale heures
n'hésitez pas direction à guyancourt à
présent les clubs du département avaient
rendez vous ce dimanche dans un
restaurant de la ville au moment où tout
autour d'une pizza partagé pour se faire
connaître aussi rapprocher les
différentes disciplines football
américain badminton ou encore judo parmi
les associations présentes
en tout une quinzaine de clubs évinois
participer à ce rendez vous organisé par
sport event 78 et propos recueillis par
tv 78 donc présenté un petit peu tout le
monde
succinctement chacun leur présenter ses
activités
et les différents événements à venir ça
permet de huy de faire du lien de sortir
de chez soi et de montrer que malgré
malgré qu'on a eu un cancer du sein ou
autres cancers
on peut faire des activités et prouver
que le sport est une activité très
importante dans la maladie ça permet
tout simplement de faire des contacts
dans un premier temps et puis d'exposer
des idées qui pourraient
qui pourrait je pense notre association
se faire connaître et puis comme j'ai
entendu pourquoi pas travailler dehors
dans l'avenir quoi un mot de cyclisme
sur piste à présent les mondiaux seront
organisée à berlin à partir de ce
mercredi 26 février du côté de la
sélection française on retrouvera
notamment un certain ryan et là le
pistard qui vient de fêter assez à 21
ans tentera de remporter sa première
médaille mondiale lui qui a déjà
participé aux championnats du monde en
2018 nous l'avons rencontré nous sommes
ce vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à mes côtés à
ryan et la halle qui vient d'être
sélectionné pour participer à ces
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste qui se dérouleront à berlin le 26
février à prochain
raynal est ce que vous êtes prêt pour
cette compétition oui je suis prêt
physiquement j'ai fait une grosse grosse
saison cet hiver avec plusieurs manches
de coupe du monde
je me suis bien préparé et là je suis en
phase d'affûtage et je me sens plutôt
bien
est ce que c'est une surprise d'être
sélectionné ou est-ce que c'est dans la
continuité finalement pas aussi un peu
dans la continuité j'avais fait pas mal
de kirin ce set cet hiver combien
j'étais un peu récompensé de ses efforts
là et voilà lâché prêt et motivé pour ce
championnat
alors votre spécialité c'est plutôt la
vitesse là où seraient sur le keirin
est ce que ça peut nous perturber ou est
ce que justement c'est une bonne manière
d'apprendre une discipline que vous ne
connaissez pas forcément à ça peut être
une bonne mère pour la prendre
le keirin ça reste total d'assez ouvert
quand même un peu plus que la vitesse
individuelle et sans pareil pour
d'autres j'ai beaucoup d'expérience je
pense à un niveau mondial du coup année
olympique en plus de ça
et ça va être que du positif que du
bonus le keirin s'est un petit peu
particulier il ya beaucoup de stratégies
qui se met en place pendant la course
quelle est votre stratégie vous en fait
ya pas trop de stratégie finalement
c'est beaucoup de bas d'instinct sur le
moment les opportunités c'est celle de
tout ça et c'est pour ça que ça fait un
peu la magie guerine c'est un peu je
vais pas dire aléatoire c'est bon c'est
quand même les meilleurs qui gagnent
mais chacun a sa chance
alors ces championnats du monde se
dérouleront à berlin est ce que c'est
une piste que vous connaissez bien et
quelles sont ses spécificités
oui j'ai déjà fait une coupe du monde à
berlin
c'est drôle une piste qui roulent très
vite si vite et c'est que les hydrates
sont assez courtes donc ce qui fait
qu'on ait beaucoup relancé dans les
virages donc ça va très très vite à
chaque fois on a ce côté roland se
relancer ça va aller vite
c'est sûr ça va aller vite et une
dernière vous avez a raté ses
championnats du monde cette année
j'imagine que vous êtes encore plus
revanchard c'est sa mort en char motivé
vraiment motivé pour pour y aller pour
les faire et voilà là je cogite tout à
l'heure je me suis bien préparé et j'ai
hâte j'ai hâte d'être à la course
c'était une petite blessure qui vous
avait empêché de participer à ces
championnats du monde
est-ce que voilà ça a été difficile à
encaisser un petit peu
c'était juste avant de décoller pour
pour la pologne mais voilà je suis passé
à autre chose je suis bien rentré depuis
et voilà de l'eau coulé sous les ponts
et maintenant je je suis motivé pour ma
peau le coût pour un nouveau mondiale on
arrive forcément dans une année
olympique
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour être
dans ces jeux olympiques participent à
ces jeux olympiques autres le plus fort
tout simplement l'équipe de france on on
est une équipe assez homogène avec un
très très gros niveau mais mondiale
finalement
on a beaucoup de coureurs qui ont
beaucoup de potentiel
mais voilà faut être le plus fort pour
être en dix ans soit une décision
discutable
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
justement les jeux olympiques moi c'est
quelque chose de grand c'est pour que
c'est le pourquoi on s'entraîne pendant
quatre ans ont travaillé durement pour
cette épreuve règne des jeux qui
arrivent tous les quatre ans mixez voilà
c'est quelque chose reims et il n'y a
pas plus grands y a pas plus gros comme
un événement pour tous portier je pense
et voilà c'est quelque chose que qui
nous touche à tout ça car vous êtes
quand même encore assez jeune
est-ce que vous misez sur ces jeux
olympiques 2020 à tokyo ou plutôt sur
les jeux olympiques de 2024 qui se
dérouleront ici au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
bah je pense toujours à tokyo je me
manque la sélection n'est pas sorti
donc la sélection n'est pas sorti on y
croit tous c'est je pense une bonne
stratégie à avoir tous tous y croire
mais bien évidemment je prends ce retour
déjà à paris qui va très très vite
arrivé et je suis déjà motivé une
médaille c'est possible sur les jeux
olympiques
bon tout comme fo de mankono départ tout
peut arriver à tout ne peut gagner voilà
dans le coin tous deux bras deux jambes
et voilà c'est ton peut gagner
à la question qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour cette année 2020 que du
positif est que du positif beaucoup de
réussite et surtout la santé
merci beaucoup rayonner la halle je
rappelle les championnats du monde se
dérouleront à berlin le 26 février
prochain on retrouvera également lors de
ces championnats du monde un pistard du
vélo-club d'elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines son nom
quentin caleyron après avoir débuté sa
carrière sur le bmx il s'est lancé sur
la piste à l'âge de 30 ans le sportif a
répondu à notre traditionnel jeu à des
trois questions
[Musique]
j'ai commencé par le bmx à la base et
j'ai décidé de me consacrer à la piste à
30 ans donc voilà un peu
une carrière bizarre mais voilà j'adore
le vélo j'ai toujours adoré le vélo j'en
fais depuis que je suis tout petit je
pense que je devais savoir faire du vélo
sans roulettes à deux ans
un an et demi voilà c'est vraiment
une discipline de coeur
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir mais premier saut
en bmx mes premiers tours de piste mais
première compétition
[Musique]
j'ai déjà fait une
une olympiade en bmx et mon objectif
principal c'est de karine sur piste et
cette fois-ci dormi au championnat du
monde
déjà championne du monde et après rio on
passe maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
dans cet agenda du rugby les finale
interacadémique de rugby féminin sont
organisées ce mercredi 26 février dans
l'après midi au lycée à jean vilar de
plaisir cet événement va regrouper 70e
joueuse de 15 à 17 ans pour nous parler
de ce rendez-vous nous recevrons un
encadrant un organisateur rihanna bea
ainsi que deux joueuses léana ullrich et
ana el hassania bonsoir alors est-ce que
ce rendez vous est un événement
important pour le lycée jean vilar
alors oui il est important pour
plusieurs raisons puisque c'est déjà une
première c'est la première année qu'on
ne rend compte une as rugby au sein
d'établissements donc de pouvoir se
qualifier tout de suite sur le
championnat inter académique c'est c'est
une belle une belle première et puis et
puis c'est aussi un événement important
pour le rugby féminin puisque puisque on
n'en parle pas mal au niveau des choses
professionnels et ce avec le rugby
amateur féminin se développe aussi donc
donc c'est une bonne chose les filles
est ce que c'est un rendez vous que vous
attendez depuis longtemps oui oui moi ça
me fait plaisir de continuer déjà le
rugby parce que au collège on était déjà
à la section sportive derby et ensuite
on a pu continuer à l'ess
holy see et comment vous ressentez cet
événement c'est dans deux jours un peu
de stress à noël battu stress parce que
déjà on joue chez nous sur nos terrains
on va pouvoir avoir tous nos amis et
puis bal rugby c'est une passion pour
nous du coup on envie d'être de donner
le meilleur de nous donc c'est un peu
stressant mais
heureux d'y participer comment va se
dérouler la compétition
alors en fait c'est une compétition qui
se déroule sur toute l'après midi
il ya une première phase de poules ou en
fait il ya six équipes donc deux poules
de trois les deux premiers de chaque
poule se qualifient pour les demi
finales et puis ensuite la finale à
halle en tant que les 70 joueuses de 15
à 17 ans quels secteurs finalement alors
ces deux académies c'est l'académie de
versailles avec trois établissements de
cette académie dont le lycée jean vilar
et l'autre academy savez khademi de
paris donc c'est des cd des lycées qui
sont en ile de france
est ce que vous êtes un petit peu
renseigné sur le niveau des autres
équipes bagages à y aller sur les
réseaux sociaux on voit à peu près le
niveau de chaque équipe
on voit à quoi il ressemble sur les
réseaux sociaux surtout puis après à
quelques vidéos sur youtube qu'on a
regardé vous prenez quelques petites
informations avant le match et du coup
c'est jouable ou par pur plaisir
oui toujours toujours jouable est ce que
vous confirmez
oui oui oui c'est jouable c'est elles en
connaissent certaines puisque elles
seules elles s'affrontent aussi en club
ou en sélection donc dans quelle belle
en connaissent l on connaisse quelques
unes mais mais bien sûr on va défendre
défendre notre part du gâteau jusqu'au
bout globalement le niveau y est
commencée c'est un bon niveau régional
oui c'est un c1 c'est un bon niveau de
clubs puisque on arrive alors ça il ya
une certaine hétérogénéité entre les
équipes tout ce qu'il ya des équipes qui
sont constitués de joueuses de clubs
comme nous moi j'ai la chance de pouvoir
m'appuyer sur un sur le club de plaisir
le club de rugby qui me fournit du coup
pas mal de joueurs issus du club auquel
j'ajoute mois des élèves débutante qui
intègre intègre la s et il ya aussi des
équipes où il ya que des élèves qui qui
débute et donc ils n'ont pas de qui
n'ont pas de passé de jose de club donc
assez assez hétérogène mais là haut
niveau interacadémiques se seront que
dès que des équipes
d'un bon niveau alors vous avez gagné le
titre de championnes académiques
l'objectif c'est forcément la gagne on
est d'accord sur ce rendez vous on est
bien d'accord
vous confirmez c'est la gagne tout fait
pour participer au championnat de france
ce serait un bel aboutissement pour la
première année déjà de l'ess
parce qu'une victoire permettrait
d'aller au championnat de france en
c'est bien ça fait les deux premières
places sont qualificatives pour le
championnat de france donc les
finalistes et le vainqueur iront aux
championnats de france mais j'ai comme
une petite impression que les filles
préféré y aller avec la première place
en poche
est ce que le public peut venir assister
un public extérieur ou lycées venir voir
là sur le la rencontre aura lieu au
stade robert barran de plaisir il ya une
grande tribune pour pouvoir accueillir
accueillir tout le monde donc n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de problème ils
peuvent ils peuvent venir nombreux alors
vous disais ça a permis de mettre en
valeur le
le rugby féminin de quelle façon ça le
met en valeur alors déjà ça on va un
petit peu à l'encontre des clichés où
beaucoup pensent que le rugby féminin
c'est que du rugby à toucher c'est pas
du rugby à toucher c'est du rugby à sare
c'est du rugby à 7
mais c'est du rugby avec contact avec
placage c'est aussi aller manquons des
clichés en termes de vitesse de jeu et
de niveau de jeu puisque le niveau est
quand même bon c'est agréable à regarder
moi qui parle c'est ma première année
que j'encadre une équipe de rugby
j'y prends vraiment plaisir donc donc
voilà donc c'est ça c'est important
et puis il ya aussi une dynamique de
groupe qui est intéressante où les
filles s'entendent bien entre elles
l'ambiance est bonne entre les équipes
ya pas de mauvais esprit
donc c'est vrai que c'est plutôt plutôt
assez assez plaisant est-ce qu'on peut
le comparer au rugby masculin où il faut
voir tout simplement un autre rugby
notre vision il faut avoir une vision
pour pouvoir du rugby féminin le ski est
compliqué à comparer celle en terme
d'intensité et de vitesse le rugby
masculin va plus vite les chocs sont
plus impressionnants
donc ça c'est assez compliqué de
comparer d'un point de vue physique
après d'un point de vue gestuelle d'un
point de vue technique on s'en rapproche
fortement
est ce que vous sentez que les choses
changent par rapport au rugby féminin
anne elle alors en fait pour nous c'est
un peu compliqué parce que à certains
moments quand on dit que ben on fait du
rugby on dit ah oui mais c'est des
filles ce n'est pas très impressionnant
si l'on s'est un peu compliqué mais plus
les choses avancent et plus on voit deux
filles qui viennent de pays qui
découvrent ce genre de sport et je pense
quelque chose en échange
mais que les personnes enfin les gens
ils ont besoin de s'habituer à la même
chose ouais pareil on sentait les
changements ouais parce que par exemple
l'année dernière on devait faire en
tournois organisés dont
je sais plus trop mou et est organisé
depuis longtemps et puis on s'est
retrouvés le matin même en disant
finalement on a mis la priorité aux
garçons donc le tournoi ben c'est pas
possible donc là on voit que tu as
évolué et trouver ça fait plaisir des
vrais arbitres merci à vous trois bêtes
passé sur ce plateau les finale
interacadémique de rugby féminin sont
programmés ce mercredi à plaisir c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]